*musique d'intro*
Avez vous des lacunes ?
Oh put*in
Celle-là elle était terrible
Est-ce que vous êtes forts pour tout ce qui est calcul
Mais vous êtes nuls pour tout ce qui est orthographe ?
Ou est-ce que vous êtes forts pour tout ce qui est orthographe
Mais vous êtes nuls pour tout ce qui est calcul ?
Moi je m'en sors assez bien dans les deux
Mais j'ai énormément de lacunes
En géographie
Et oui ! Et pourquoi ? Bien, c'est simple !
J'me souviens très bien de ces cours d'histoire
En 4ème, 3ème
Où il fallait apprendre les cartes du monde
Voilà il y avait plein de cartes à apprendre
Lucas il a fait quoi au lieu d'apprendre les cartes
Il a jouer son féca level 72 sur Dofus
Et il a eu 6/20 au contrôle
Ça me passionnait pas du tout la géographie
Et je n'ai jamais fait l'effort
D'aller sur une carte du monde
Et d'apprendre où y a quel pays
J'connais un peu la base
Portugal, Espagne, France, Allemagne, Angleterre ça va
Mais y a pleins de pays que j'place pas du tout au bon endroit
Et aujourd'hui, on va jouer à un jeu qui va mettre à l’épreuve
mon skill négatif en géographie
Sa s'appelle, Map zoom Quiz.com
Et le but est extrêmement simple
on va avoir un plant aérien d'une ville assez zoomé
mais il faut deviner quelle capitale d'Europe c'est
Et si tu ne trouves pas, car toi aussi tu joues à Dofus au lieu d'aller en cours d'histoire
Et bien y a un bouton pour dé-zoomer un peu l'image et avoir plus d’élément dessus
du coup c'est plus facile pour deviner ce que s'est
et tu peux dé-zoomer jusqu'à voir la carte du monde, voilà
et il y a plusieurs Quiz de dispo
y a les grandes villes au U.S. mais ça on est nul
Les parcs national (*nationaux) je t'en parle même pas
Les lacs aux États-Unis, non mais mec faut arrêter !
Mais il y a les capitales européennes c'est celui-là qui nous intéressent
Quelles capitales de villes d'Europe c'est
Oh!!!
Euh!! Ah il y a un peu d'eau
Ils foutent le doute !
ILS FOUTENT LE DOUTE !!
Parce que les villes où il y a énormément d'eau
Ah mais non c'est une capitale
Donc ça peut pas etre Venise
Parce que Venise c'est pas une capitale
AH!!!
Y'en a dans le ciboulot
On va de-zoomer un peu
OK! Y'a de la mer direct
Y'a que la mer
Ici y'a les petits bateaux des riches
Ici on peut les voir bien sur
Ça doit être Espagne
Non mais Espagne ça ressemble pas a ça mec
Qu'est ce qui est en bord de mer et qui peut ressembler à ça
J'ai l'impression que c'est l’Angleterre mec
Je sais pas pourquoi j'ai l'impression que c'est l'Angleterre
*bruit de clavier*
AHHH !! AH AH AH!
J'ai marquer Londres mec
C'etait Reykjavik en Island
Non mais on est est sérieux la
Et bien sur je saurais situer cette ville sur une carte
Reykjavik capitale de l'Islande
Mais ouais put*n
Y'avait plein de verdures partout la
J'aurais du deviner
Ah!
Bon c'est pas grave c’était pas facile non plus
On va pas se mito
Ça va
Sur une map c'est là
Ah c'est la l'Islande !
*il rigole*
Ah mec !
Je croyais que c'était entre le Royaume-Unis et la Norvège
Mec je suis le pire. C'est un truc de ouf!
J'ai honte. J'ai envie de me flinguer
Bon, c'est pas grave, c'est des choses qui arrivent
Suivant! On va se rattraper!
OUH! Des toits comme ça!
Déjà, la météo, il y a la chaleur qui tape je peux la sentir d'ici
OUF!
C'est très coloré au niveau des toits
Très luminueux
Mouais
Ici, là il y a un mec en débardeur
Ça montre qui fait au moins 40-35-40 degrés
35-40 degrés c'est quoi?
C'Est Espagne ou Portugal
Bof! On fait plaisir à nos amis portugais. On les rince.
*Bruits de clavier*
*Il rit*
AH! Je prends la fuite!
Mec, franchement. Je sais que
Là vous vous me dites : "Non il fait exprès et tout. C'est une grosse merde"
Franchement, je ne fais pas exprès. Je me confie à vous
C'est mon gros, gros, gros, gros point faible la géo
Situer les endroits, connaître les capitales
Là, ça m'a mis mal quand même. Lisbonne
Alors, Lisbonne, est-ce que c'est ça? Si ça trouve, c'est même pas ça
OUI!!!! C'ÉTAIT LISBONNE!!!!
Ok, c'est vert. Allez c'est L'Islande
Non, c'est vert, mais c'est raisonnable, il y a juste pas mal d'arbres
Et ce que je note surtout c'est qu'il y a beaucoup d'eau
Regardez. Ici il y a un canal, ici un autre canal
Ici y'a un autre canal
Il y en a absolument partout. Il y a beaucoup de ponts aussi
Ça me fait penser à Amsterdam un peu
D'ailleurs je suis allé à Amsterdam il n'y a pas très longtemps
Pas pour faire ce que vous pensez
J'ai été étonné de la ville. C'est super beau
J'imaginais pas ça aussi beau. C'est magnifique!
Ici je crois qu'il y a le musée de la bite
Rigolez, mais c'est vraiment un musée que j'ai visité là-bas
Et c'était vraiment nul, n'y allez pas, surtout pas
C'est nul à chier, mais bon tu vas à Amsterdam
Tu vois le musée de la bite, ça te fait rire, t'y vas, voilà
Bon bref, fin de l'histoire. Amsterdam, vrai ou faux?
Mais sept ans plus tard, on est bien!
Alors, allez! Aaahhh!
Il y a des parcs immenses partout
Qu'est-ce que ça peut être?
Là, les mecs qui si connaissent un peu doivent se dire
"Mais attends c'est évident c'est le parc national du du Kaboustistan"
C'est marrant parce que rien qu'avec la couleur de l'image genre
Et des toits, on arrive à savoir
S'il faisait beau ou pas, la température et du coup
Deviner la zone géographique
Ou alors c'est mon esprit un peu tordu qui développe cette technique secrète
Attends je zoom un peu pour être sûr
Attends! Il y a encore un parc là!
Non ce n'est pas un truc en Suède ça?
Attends, tends, tends, tends...
En Suède en plus la capitale c'est
Putain il y a Dice là-bas, ceux qui développent BF
C'est... Ah! Lucas!
Ah! Je l'ai sur le bout de la LANGUE! AAAHH!
AAAHH! NON! Putain!
Mec, je l'ai sur le bout de la langue
Ah! Ah! Ben mec, ben voilà c'est Stockholm.
Stockholm c'est marqué
*RIRE*
J'ai jamais compris pourquoi les mecs disent je l'ai sur le bout de la langue
Il n'y en a jamais un qui a fait ça, c'est bizarre
Tu l'as, tu le prends et tu lis *soupir*
Ne vous désabonnez s'il-vous-plait *rire*
Ah merde! Franchement quand j'avais 12 ans
et que je jouais à Dofus, je pensais déjà à cette blague
Aujourd'hui, j'ai enfin osé la faire
C'est, c'est une sorte de rêve qui vient de se réaliser
Merci à tous! Voilà!
C'était très, très gênant... Alors!
C'est Stockholm, j'ai un sentiment qui me dit
C'est Stockholm, bien joué
C'est Athènes en Grèce, mec
Je suis tellement con
Mais je ne savais pas qu'il y avait des parcs comme ça immenses en Grèce
Je ne savais pas que la Grèce, c'était là!
*Rire* Je rigole, je rigole
Non on ne va pas abuser. Non, non, tranquille, tranquille
Il y a un moment, où on va se calmer quand même *inspiration*
Bon, bon, bon, bon, bon...
Alors la température, on est sur un petiiiiit...
Un petit 18 degrés *bruit bouche*
Il faut que je dézoome. Pareil il y a un très grand parc ici
Ça ressemble trop à ce que l'on a vu avant
Ici il y a juste un énorme fleuve
Ici il y a un stade. Attends, c'est pas Paris quand même?
Non, n'importe quoi. À Paris il n'y a pas du tout autant d'herbe ici
Clairement c'est pas Paris
J'ai envie de croire à Berlin ou à Stockholm
Attends, je dézoome encore. Je ne suis pas sûr
AAAHH! Mais il y a tellement d'herbe autour mec
C'est clairement pas Paris, mais c'est un peu paumé
Attends, encore un peu voir. OH Non!
Mais là, mais mec, c'est au milieu de nul part mon pote
Qu'est-ce qui est au milieu de nul part?
Un pays d'Europe où dont la capitale est au milieu de nul part
Pire carte, ça c'est la pire carte, je saigne des yeux
Allez! Salut!
Bon allez, consulter la page, allez fait moi rêver
Cliquez ici. Non, mais c'est, arrête
Ok, mais non, putain, c'est si dur de trouver un carte sur Google?
Ah! C'est Norway, c'est Oslo, mec c'est sûr, c'est sûr
Regarde! UP! Oslo
NON!!!!
C'EST PRAGUE!
Non, mais mec, vous aviez deviné, en vrai?
Vous aviez deviné?
*...aux affaires qui agit pratique. C'est ce sens qu'à conserve aujourd'hui le mot pragmatique
*Rires* Je raconte ce qui vient de se passer *Rires*
Bon, on vient de trouver la ville de Prague
Vous me connaissez, je suis le Youtuber le plus drôle de Youtube
Et je fais des jeux de mots vraiment exceptionnels
Je voulais donc dire
Aaah! On n'a pas trouvé Prague, mais on est très pragmatique
Ou un truc du genre
Mais pour que cette blague se passe bien
Je voulais être sûr à 100 % du sens du mot pragmatique
Je suis donc allé sur un site qui en donne la définition
Et je me suis tapé un spam, euh... audio. Voilà!
Si cette histoire t'as intéressée, n'hésite pas à...
m'envoyer un nude, ça me fera plaisir
ou ne fait rien et passons à autre chose
Damit! Qu'est-ce que ça peut être?
Y'a un peu d'arbres, c'est pas Paris
Ah! Il y a une grande roue là
Vous l'avez?
Putain! Ah! La grande roue mec elle m'a fait kiffé
Et c'est London bien sûûûûrrrrr!!!
Uuuuuuuurrrrrrr!
(Chante) *C'est un très beau jour*
*C'était très très skillé*
*J'ai trouvé London grâce à la London Eye*
C'est le nom de la grande roue, si vous ne saviez pas, voilà
On apprend des choses que les CE 2 savent déjà
Mais bon on se sent bien
Franchement, avec de l'eau comme ça encore
Est-ce que c'est pas Stockholm?
Non mais que je n'ai pas sorti ce morceau de papier de ma bouche pour rien
Qui est servi à quelque chose
Non, non, non, c'est pas Stockholm
Wow! Il y a un parc mon pote
Il est immense!
Oh là! Ouh là! Par contre C'est ultra urbain!
J'ai l'impression que c'est en Allemagne.
Mec, c'est en Allemagne, c'est Berlin
*Bruits de clavier*
AAAAAAHHHHHH!!!!
OUHHH!!!!!
Pardon, excusez-moi
Peut-être vous ne comprenez pas ma joie
Je ne la comprends moi-même qu'à moitié
C'est juste que je suis profondément nul en géo
Et là j'arrive à deviner, ça me fait hyper plaisir!
Ce jeu a été inventé pour te rassurer quand tu pues la merde en géo clairement
Clairement le mec qui a codé le jeu c'était un gars qui
était max guildes sur Dofus, qui jouait aux mêmes heures que moi
Il a pris sa vengeance sur la vie en faisant ce jeu, mon gars
*Inspiration*
Alors, ah! il y a une grande roue là!
*Bruits soulagement*
(chante) AUX ARMES CITOYENS
PARIS
*Musique*
Bonsoir messieurs, aujourd’hui, vous savez ce que l'on va faire?
On va...
C'est faux! On ne troune pas les vidéos à la chaîne
comme ça chez Squeezie Industries, hein!
Et bien voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur
Map zoom quiz.com
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous à plu
et je vous rassure, il n'y a pas que ce quiz-là
Ben, vous l'avez vu au début de la vidéo
Il y a le quiz  pour trouver les lacs, les grandes villes des U.S. Etc.
Je ne sais pas si on peut en créer soi-même, ça serait cool
Bon en tout cas n'hésitez pas à jouer à ce jeu
C'est très amusant pour renforcer votre skill en géographie
Je suis très content de ma prestation mec
Parce qu'elle était tout simplement
Excellente
Allez à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
Allez, bon vent, allez, allez, allez jouer là!
Et à bientôt!
*Musique*
Qu'est-ce que vous foutez là encore? C'est fini!
C'est terminé!
Il faut cliquer dans une des vidéos là en suggestion et c'est terminé
Allez, à bientôt!